if you've been telling yourself this is  the ugliest or most unique house you've  ever seen well then you better see the  inside because there's literally 35 feet  of red rock cliff face built into this  perry colorado home don't worry because  the home is moving ready so you won't  have to touch a thing the perfect work  from home space does exist and it's this  ugly one i've got three important  questions about this home though like  how many animals live in here number two  do you use a mop or a duster or hose how  do you clean this what's the protocol  and finally number three what's its name  you can't call it the rock for obvious  reasons but it looks kind of like a  stoney or my personal favorite senior  cliff i could see myself living in this  ugly home and i think you'll could see  yourself living here too for more ugly  homes be sure to check out ugliest house  in america ugly in paradise on sundays 8  7 central on hgtv